[Música]
mi nombre es juan carlos riveros soy
biólogo y no me arrepiento de esta
manera al medio en broma medio en serio
un grupo de amigos nos reuníamos hacia
el final de la carrera para conversar
sobre los problemas y desafíos de lo que
significaba ser biólogo en los 80
llamamos a nuestro grupo ecólogos
anónimos un espacio para discutir
conversar intercambiar ideas sobre los
problemas sobre las frustraciones de
llevar a cabo biología la conservación
en los ochentas en esos momentos el
mayor problema era la gente la gente que
hacía uso los recursos pescadores
leñadores cazadores gente que había
hecho lo mismo por decenas cientos de
años pero que en esa perspectiva en esa
visión de la conservación eran los
enemigos los malos de la película
en el año 83 estaba al norte de lima en
una laguna cerca de huacho estudiando la
vida en esas lagunas y eventualmente
vimos como la de la orilla del mar se
iban acumulando las aves 10 20 30 un
momento eran docenas hasta un alcanzaba
la vista uno no podía caminar por la
playa sin básicamente chocar como
algunas de ellas no sabíamos lo que
estaba pasando y simplemente nos
invitamos a ver cómo agonizaba me morían
en la playa luego nos enteramos que 6
millones de aves murieron ese año a
consecuencia del niño 80 y 83
un profesor en la universidad nos dijo
luego que el niño era como un ensayo
general del cambio climático un evento
que veríamos en unos 100 años
pero han pasado apenas 30 años de que
escuche esa frase y el clima ya había
cambiado en realidad nadie que haya
nacido después de 1984 ha tenido un
verano normal años después estaba en el
sur de lima- en marcona estudiando
pingüinos pingüinos peruanos aprendíamos
de sus costumbres cómo interactúan entre
ellos en cierto sentido aprendimos a
verlo como una familia todavía muy bien
hasta que tuve que volver a lima a ver a
mi familia humana y al regresar a la
marcona ya no estaban los pingüinos que
había pasado pensamos un momento
depredadores cazadores furtivos alguna
enfermedad pero no era el niño del 87 y
luego el del 92 y luego el del 97 y
entonces lo que eran fenómenos se
convirtieron en eventos lo que era
extraño lo que era irregular se
convierte en algo corriente y es así
como empezamos a hablar de cambio
climático
nuestras discusiones entonces cambiaron
de tono de conversar de animales y de
especies individuales comenzamos a los
ecosistemas que se estaban poniendo en
peligro de pronto vimos que el de océano
que en toda su inmensidad era
tremendamente frágil el océano en
realidad había todo como un inmenso
radiador como una especie de aire
acondicionado que había reducido el
calentamiento planeta lo había absorbido
dentro de sí y a partir de ello
básicamente algunas especies estaban
desapareciendo los corales algunos
bosques de algas y eventualmente en la
mayor riqueza pesquera se estaba
distribuyendo de otra manera nuestro
país entre ellos imagínense un futuro en
el cual no hubiera la riqueza
gastronómica que tenemos en base de
pescado como le explicamos de nuestros
hijos las sensaciones de un ceviche de
unos choritos a la chalaca y una
parihuela con qué sabores los comparamos
como le decimos a nuestros nietos que
antes no podíamos entrar en la playa y
tomaron un plato de cebiche y mirar el
sol todo eso se podría perder
ahora respiremos una vez
dos veces
una segunda bocanada de aire es el aire
es al mar
la mitad del oxígeno que respiramos es
producido en el mar por pequeñas
microscópicas plantas que día a día
están ahí haciendo eso generan el
oxígeno para que nosotros respiramos
la vida misma proviene del mar
los primeros meses de días pasamos
flotando en el líquido de vientre
materno
y un bebé al nacer tres cuartas partes
de su peso es agua en cierto sentido y
llevamos al mar con nosotros a lo largo
de nuestras vidas
como en el mar nos ha dado alimento
recreación fuente de trabajo regula el
clima y encima nos da oxígeno
pero que hemos hecho por el mar lo hemos
tratado como un botadero donde van a dar
todos los residuos de civilización
aguas residuales desechos industriales
pesticidas fertilizantes plásticos
millones de toneladas de plástico que a
veces usamos por unas pocas horas
y sin embargo el mar sigue ahí cuál es
el límite hasta dónde puede resistir
este gigante azul tanta presión de
nuestra parte mi historia en la biología
de la conservación es la historia de la
conquista de mis miedos
le tenía miedo a los insectos y empezar
precisamente estudiando todos los bichos
que pude le tenía miedo las alturas y
aprendí a escalar árboles ya descolgarme
de los acantilados para estudiar los
nidos de las aves yo tenía el mío al mar
por su inmensidad y su bravura y hoy en
día le tengo mucho respeto
mi mayor miedo hoy en día es que no
puedo usar mis hijos del mar de la
manera que lo he hecho yo que tus hijos
no puedan costar esos beneficios y no se
trata solo de las ballenas y los
delfines y todos los animalitos sino
eventualmente de nuestra propia
supervivencia como especie
hoy no basta con ser un buen ciudadano
con reducir nuestra huella ecológica o
con reciclar tienes que organizarte
tienes que participar esta no es una
pelea o no es una batalla solo de
biólogos y conservacionistas es una
batalla por la raza humana tienes que
aprender
tienes que informarte y tienes que
ayudar a que otros informe
ayuda en redes sociales se activó en las
campañas para proteger el mar para crear
áreas protegidas y reducir el ingreso de
plásticos al océano tienes que ser
activo en todos los frentes para luchar
contra el cambio climático esa es la
batalla de tu generación porque mi
generación creó el problema y ahora es
tu tiempo
la mayor parte de mi vida ha sido
biólogo he visto cosas maravillosas he
visto cosas increíbles que no creí que
existieran siquiera pero también es yo
testigo de cómo el planeta ha cambiado
de todo el daño que le estamos haciendo
y eventualmente la necesidad que tenemos
de tener acciones hoy en día estamos en
un punto de quiebre de ti depende hoy en
día que podamos hacerle frente al cambio
climático y ayudar a salvar el planeta
de ti depende que sus hijos tengan la
posibilidad de gozar de playas limpias y
de peces sabrosos